this is a production of Cornell
University
so what I'd like to talk to you about is
what I see is two very major issues
where I think the u.s. in particular can
play a major part that through
innovations I hope I can convince you
that at least scientifically we can play
a major part in feeding the world and
fueling the world from plants by 2050
but there are a number of social
barriers acceptability issues which you
know we're also going to have to
overcome and may the the larger
challenge but most of my talk will be on
the science and why I think these goals
are our possibilities so just um like
parts of Cornell Illinois is a
land-grant University this is our
Institute for genomic biology and I put
this picture in because in front of it
those maize plants are growing on the
morrow plots which is the oldest
agricultural experiment outside of
rothamsted England so mazes being grown
there since 1876 so if you like it's one
of the longest sustainability
experiments and existence so samples
have been taken every year so we can
look at changes in soil properties and
sustainability and this was Professor
morrow when he was setting these plots
up I'm almost 150 years ago we're so
proud of the fact that like you we have
alumni who World Food Prize laureates
married L Clinton and Rob Fraley who I
think importantly we rewarded the World
Food Prize for their work on bio
engineering of crops which is perhaps
quite a change in the wards and maybe
telling us about the role of new
technology
in moving through production forward so
what I want to look at they're really
three issues addressing food security
under global change and as upset at the
beginning i'll be talking a lot more
tomorrow about global global change and
that things that and also the issue of
whether we can have bio energy without
conflict with food production and then
I'll finish briefly talking about some
of the barriers as I see them to moving
these opportunities forward so dressing
food security on the global change if we
look at apologize this is data for 2013
but that's the most complete global data
we have our present if we look at the
most important crops in terms of
productivity of food primary foodstuffs
then today amazes number one over a
thousand million tons produced in 2013
four people stood up at the back there
are lots of seats here please please
come and sit down because it standing up
is a good way to keep awake during my
talks but it's uncomfortable on your
feet so so so please feel free to come
and sit now so so maze over a thousand
million tonnes rice next very closely
followed by wheat and then soy somewhat
distant fourth but of course soy is an
extremely important source of dietary
protein both in animal feeds and in
because our food for us the United
States plays a big part in the
production of these crops although we
only have a tenth of the world area
devoted to maize in fact we produce over
one-third of the world's maze we produce
about a third of the world's soy and the
significant part of the
world's wheat as well and the United
States remains the biggest exporter of
these primary foodstuffs so what happens
in the United States is actually very
important for costs of many of these
foods globally so why with all that
production why should we be concerned
well the United Nations Food and
Agricultural organization report looking
forward said well by 2050 we're going to
have a third more people on the planet
but they are going to be far more urban
than they are today so we're seeing
rapid urbanization diets and urban areas
are historically different they use more
processed food more animal products
because people have a higher income and
so when you put those two things
together more people and different diets
they estimated that we need seventy
percent more primary foodstuffs by 2050
than we have today thirty percent more
by 2030 and because there isn't that
much more land than could support these
primary foodstuffs that would have to be
achieved by making more per hectare of
land so are we able to meet this
requirement well if we look at what has
happened historically so this figure
goes back to nineteen sixty we can see
what appears to be a fairly steady rise
in the yields of wheat and rice this is
average global yields of these crops per
hectare of land so we can see that for
both of these crops it's more than
doubled over that nearly 60-year period
so if we project that forward would say
well by 2050 will increase this much but
if we actually look at how much we need
of these crops then we need to be
following this trajectory and clearly
we're we're not at the present time and
indeed this is beginning to go forward
into the costs of these primary
foodstuffs so for example if we look at
wheat prices back in 2006 about 130
dollars per ton by the end of 2013 there
were three sixty dollars now I know
everything has come down in price since
that time including gasoline but this is
at the beginning of March it was still
three hundred and twelve dollars per ton
and this is considered to be a low in
prices fao estimate that we're probably
going to see a doubling of food prices
primary food prices on a seven-year
cycle given present trends now we don't
really feel that impact very much
because these primary foodstuffs are
really a very small part of the cost of
what our household budgets but in cause
some parts of the world household budget
sixty seventy percent of it goes on
basic foodstuffs so if they double in
price that is a catastrophe for those
those areas the other side of this
problem is that we aren't really
improving yields year-on-year the way we
were if we look at the percentage
increase over previous decades China
India and Indonesia are the biggest
producers of rice in the world if we
look at their improvement in your per
hectare then in the 70s and 80s when
dwarf cultivars were coming in from the
Green Revolution yields are improving
forty percent per decade if we go
forward now to the last decade we're now
into single-figure improvement
this is despite the fact that countries
like China are spending a hundred times
what they were in the 80s on rice
improvements so more and more effort is
needed and yet we're not getting the
same return that we were and indeed
there's a fear that rather than going on
a linear trajectory that we're actually
getting into a stage where we're seeing
a flattening out of yield improvement
year by year and of course part of this
may be impacted global change part of it
maybe they were just reaching biological
limits on some aspects of crop
improvement and this is a another study
which was looking at wheat yields
through the world where some areas are
showing improvement but many the yellow
are showing stagnation and red is where
yields have actually collapsed so in
fact we over the last decade the average
yield of wheat per hectare of land has
not improved at all so why might this be
why did we do so well in the Green
Revolution and now we're struggling
today well um I'll only put up one
equation and this is a simple equation
but I want to use it to explain why this
may be and this is looking at your
potential so I if we haven't if we have
a given variety of a crop what is the
maximum yield it can achieve at a site
if there are no pests and diseases we're
giving it the nutrients and water it
needs so why might yield potential
improvements in your potential be
stagnating well if we look at what
determines your potential first of all
is the amount of sunlight that's
available during the growing season of
that crop secondly it's how good is that
crop up capturing that sunlight thirdly
how good is it at converting that
captured sunlight into biomass
and how good is it then partitioning
that biomass into the parts of the crop
we really care about so the grain of
rice the seed of soybean and so on now
these are some numbers for a modern
soybean cultivar growing on a university
farm where we measured radiation
interception we followed the growth of
the crop and so we find is that actually
the interception efficiency this is
visible radiation because photosynthesis
only uses visible radiation was 89% and
sixty percent of the biomass ended up in
the seeds so if you think about sort of
putting a seed in the ground it's got to
cover the ground really these figures
are pretty remarkable already and it's
hard to see we can make them any better
if our crop is going to have any more if
it's going to have some seed pods it's
going to have some stems to hold the
seed then getting much better than sixty
percent seems unlikely and this in
particular is what we really changed in
the Green Revolution many pre Green
Revolution rice and wheat cultivars had
a partitioning efficiency of about
thirty percent or harvest index of
thirty percent today they're around
sixty percent interception efficiency
has been improved as well so these are
perhaps theoretical maxima for
interception and partitioning this is
what we achieve but if we look at
conversion efficiency which is largely
photosynthesis then that falls far short
of the maximum and this is something
that we appear not to have improved in
breeding for improved your potential in
crops so do we know that if we did
improve photosynthesis we get any more
yield
what is the evidence we have for that
well this was something I was able to
set up when I first moved to Illinois in
1999 we called it a face system and
basically what these rings do and this
was really to investigate global change
is that this green you can see here now
this I call it a ring but it's really an
octagon these pipes release carbon
dioxide according to wind speed and wind
direction so if the wind is coming from
this direction then co2 is released so
that it is blown across the ring and of
course the higher the wind speed the
more co2 we release it took about a year
of engineering to get this right but now
we can elevate co2 to what we think will
be the level in 2050 we put the
apparatus in as soon as we've sown the
crop and we keep it in place until the
crops dried down then we remove the
apparatus so we can bring in small plot
combines so we achieve within plus or
minus ten percent of our target for
pretty well ninety percent of the time
so the engineers managed to get it right
so within here you've got elevated co2
now carbon dioxide is a limiting
substrate for photosynthesis so
photosynthesis come dioxide plus light
plus water gives you carbohydrate co2 is
limiting so if you give it more co2 you
get more photosynthesis does this give
us more yield it gives us 25 percent
more photosynthesis and it gives us
about sixteen percent more yield in
soybean about twelve percent more in
rice fifteen percent more more in wheat
so we know that if we can boost
photosynthesis we can get more yield and
if we put this back into our equation we
can see conversion efficiency has gone
up
this isn't measuring photosynthesis is
measuring the amount of biomass we get a
unit of light capture by the plant and
this ends up in significantly more more
yield we've been doing this since the
year 2000 and we routinely see these
yield increases now what I don't want to
give you the impression is that well
rising co2 is good because that's going
to give us more yield rising co2 causes
a lot of other problems including rising
temperature order precipitation patterns
all of which are going to impact our
crops and we found many things that
wouldn't have been predicted without
doing these experiments one of the
expectations was that as co2 Rises pest
damage the crops would go down because
there's more carbon and less nitrogen in
theory so insect pests have to work
harder to get the nitrogen they need for
their proteins and this is one of the
biggest pests of maize in the Midwest
the Western corn rootworm what it what
it does is in the fall it will come into
the soybean it will feed a little bit on
the soybean and lay its eggs ready for
the next crop because it's in a soybean
maize rotation which this past has
adapted to and so it'll lay its eggs in
soybean and so the thinking was well
this would be less of a pest and indeed
ipcc actually put that into its report
it's in several publications but
apparently these insects are illiterate
and so they didn't know what they were
supposed to do and what we found was
actually in elevated co2 they laid twice
the number of eggs and if you combined
rising ozone with rising co2 the
situation was even worse and then my
colleague or colleagues avin dilution
may Berenbaum looked at
some other paths and indeed they found
that Japanese beetle damage double the
insects live longer they produce more
young and the same was true with the
soybean aphid as well so there are many
unexpected impacts of rising co2 but
what he did show is well if we can boost
photosynthesis we can get more yield so
can we do that breeders really don't
seem to have managed to select from all
photosynthesis there's a good reason for
that there's very little variation in
photosynthesis in the germ plasm so can
we intervene can we perhaps through
engineering get more photosynthesis and
this is I'd say very timely because it
appears to be the only remaining way we
can get more yield potential we can
obviously improve disease resistance
agronomy and so on but in terms of
genetic yield potential it looks like
the only one of those three things we
have left to improve we know the process
in a great deal of detail is probably
the most studied of all plant processes
we know every step of the pathway every
gene involved every protein involved how
they're assembled and so on we also have
high performance computing which can
allow us to simulate the whole process
in silico and crop transformation is
becoming increasingly routine even in
the public domain so I just want to give
you sort of an example of that in in
practice one of the things that my
former student and now collaborators
young man jus conducted when he was
doing his PhD was to take or all of the
hundred steps of the photosynthetic
process and then described them as a
series of link differential equations
and of course after two and a half years
of work we were eventually able to get
this
to start delivering something that in
silico look photosynthetically like the
response of a leaf so the next thing can
then do once you have that is you can
then say well okay we're now simulating
imagine this is like a car production
line with many different steps you can
now simulate the whole thing in silico
and you can say okay I have a hundred
workers on my production line where
should I be investing those hundred
workers so what you can then do is apply
an evolutionary algorithm which
basically takes one step at random takes
away a worker or ads on a worker and
sees whether it makes any difference to
the system because 99 times out of 100
you just making it worse but every so
often you get one which makes it better
you keep that one and then you go
through the whole process all over again
and I guess what I do like to say about
this is we always say it's not rocket
science but in this case we could say it
was rocket science because what we're
trying to do is numerically integrate a
system of over a hundred link
differential equations and this is what
it's called a stiff system because some
things are changing very rapidly others
are changing very slowly and this person
here Eric distiller was a mathematician
who was working on the dynamics of
balancing NASA rockets and apparently
that is a stiff system and he'd found
algorithms for dealing with these stiff
systems and so we work together with
Eric to actually solve this problem in
simulating the photosynthetic system and
we use his algorithm to the present day
so anyway this is just a part of what
the in silico simulation was telling us
so these are looking at enzymes involved
in carbon metabolism so when the plant
has taken up carbon die
oxide the processing of it and the
regeneration of the carbon dioxide
acceptor and what really stuck out this
is a logarithmic base here was that it
said this enzyme we should have ten
times more than we we have and if you
come to the talk tomorrow i can tell you
why we think that is but let them raise
the question is well if you elevate this
do you really see more photosynthesis so
should say this is where it sits in
metabolism here is the point rubisco the
enzyme most abundant protein on the
planet it's the one that fixes carbon
dioxide implant leaves and then that is
reduced the carbohydrate and then it's
an auto catalytic cycle so it's adding
carbon all the time so carbon is coming
in some is draining off for sucrose and
starch and the rest has to be recycled
and s BPA's sits in this recycling phase
so it's a key enzyme we we know from
reducing the enzyme that it can slow
down photosynthesis so if you increase
it can it give you more and this is from
my colleague in England Christine rains
they put this into tobacco and here are
her three different events with elevated
s BPA's enzyme and here is her
untransformed material so Christine
showed that in the greenhouse in England
and then we collaborated with Christine
to put it back in the field in Illinois
we also tested in our face system as
well and and indeed in the field we were
able to get more biomass produced by
just as one manipulation so with really
as Bob mentioned we've been looking
theoretically many other ways in which
you might be able to boost
photosynthesis and
then a couple of years ago we were lucky
that the Gates Foundation been reading
what we've been writing and sort of said
in a roundabout way well how about we
put our money where your mouth is and
you show us whether you can really do
this and so we were using tobacco as our
testbed because we've got ideas coming
from many different places so we put
those constructs into one cultivar of
tobacco regenerate those and then put
them out into replicated field trials to
really find out which manipulation might
give us more yield and I just show you
one of these that been working on this
is joint with Chris and I oggis group
university of california berkeley where
we showed in theory that if during the
day the upper leaves of a crop get more
Sun than they can use so they have to
dissipate that absorbed sunlight
otherwise it will actually become toxic
to the leaf if they can't dissipate that
sunlight energy they start to bleach and
so what Chris what the leaf does is it
then brings in quenchers so molecules
which can basically convert that absorb
light energy into heat so it harmlessly
loses I've energy as heat but but if the
leaf goes into the shade for example for
cloud and now light is limiting its
still dissipating that energy is heat so
and it takes about 30 minutes to an hour
for it to recover and regain its
efficiency so we shown from a modeling
perspective that this could this could
lower productivity by about thirty
percent and Krishna yogi sort of read
our paper and said well I think I've got
a way to speed up this so he sent us his
constructs we put them into tobacco
and we we checked that they did
physiologically what we thought they
should and this shows that they're
recovering so this shows that they
respond far more rapidly than the
wild-type and we could also pick those
out with fluorescence imaging which is
another way we can look at this but then
most importantly when we put them in the
field this is really what they the
wild-type look like and these are his
plants and of course i should say though
all of these plants if you boost
photosynthesis initially you see a
response which is much better than the
final yield because during the
exponential phase of growth you it's
like compound interest okay if you get
one percent more that's compounded than
the plants growing faster when the
canopy closes that compound interest no
longer applies but nevertheless these
plants were the biomass was about twenty
five percent greater so we're quite
excited by that we've got others coming
through this year so now I want to move
on to bioenergy why I think so basically
in that segment I think that they're
armed biotechnological ways that we
could have a second Green Revolution but
it is biotechnology bioenergy has
attracted a lot of interest and of
course now what we're hearing is well
hey we're producing as much oil as we're
we're consuming you know the US doesn't
have a problem but I know I have two
grandchildren and I wonder what is it
going to be like when they you know when
they want to do have a lifestyle like
that we have is all really going to be
as cheap as it is today are we as I
believe going to find this is really
devastating for our environment and we
do have to wean ourselves off of fossil
fuels if there
things hit then we really do need a bio
energy strategy and to be realistic to
produce significant amounts of biofuels
from plants it's not going to be there
tomorrow if we want something in 20
years we need to be starting today so we
shouldn't be looking at the situation
today we should be looking at the future
I I personally feel and this is a paper
that Chris Somerville and I published in
science while ago that really Brazil has
been a model of doing this they've like
the rest of the world sugarcane in
Brazil was in decline because the world
decided it now have plenty of artificial
sweeteners there was less demand for
sugar we were using corn for making high
fructose corn syrup probably not a good
thing but it was competing wish with
sugar from sugar cane so Brazil's she
became was in decline as was the USA's
as was the Caribbean and then they had a
crisis where they couldn't afford
gasoline they decided to make ethanol
from sugar cane and they really haven't
looked back since they did that in 2012
was the first year in which a more
gallons of ethanol was sold on four
quarts and Brazil than than gasoline and
indeed they've also been exporting in
some years as well so they managed to do
this by really reoccupying abandoned
sugar cane land and then also moving now
on to some fairly low grade pasture and
managing to restore that agronomically
so it really isn't competing with their
food production in any significant way
and if you look Brazilian government is
now mapped out where you could grow
sugarcane so so they've really ruled out
areas that require deforestation
competition with food crops and the the
Amazon region the pants
region and so on most of this land is
really around San Paulo state where of
course they have the biggest demand for
liquid fuels but if you take that 16
nearly sixty four million hectares and
you look at how much ethanol could be
produced that would be about fifteen
percent of all global liquid fuel use so
we'll make Brazil if you like the Saudi
Arabia a second Saudi Arabia but with
the advantage that they have a
sustainable I'm renewable and apparently
indefinite if you like oil well and of
course we in the 48 lower states at
least we can grow relatively little
sugar cane although i'd say we're under
utilizing the areas where we can grow it
and because hawaii which was a bit
cheeky aim producer has a lot of
abandoned land as less porto rico that
could be used but of course what has
come onto the scene now is samuel osich
ethanol where we could make ethanol by
digesting down cellulose and
hemicellulose to release the sugars and
ferment those to ethanol and indeed
we're seeing the first commercial plants
poet has its first commercial plant in
iowa which is using corn stover to
digest the cellulose down to glucose and
the Hemi cellulose down to pentoses and
is now using that for ethanol production
but if we think beyond our food crops
what this opens up is the opportunity to
use almost any plant material so it
gives us an idea to reimagine
agriculture and this is a wish list of
what our ideal crop would look like it
will be a c4 plan because c4 plants are
more productive it would have a long
growing season it will recycle its
nutrients we don't need nutrients to
make ethanol you know
feedstock so it's completely different
to a food crop and be productive on
marginal non arable land where it won't
compete with with food crops and so I
just once showing a wire field crops are
really not well suited to this task now
we're very proud of the productivity we
get out of our maize plants in Illinois
but if we look at their use of this is
the course of solar radiation this is
how much the corn crop gets so all of
this is wasted we also grow winter wheat
does a good job of capturing this
early-season radiation but then mrs. all
of this perennials really do have
generally do a better job because this
is a poplar and of course willows are
similar they already have reserves so
that when temperatures become warm
enough they can expand their leaves very
quickly and do a much better job of
capturing radiation and this is a grass
Miscanthus giganteus which really fits
these specs very well and I should say
there's something I've worked on for 30
years most of it in in Europe where
actually that table I showed you is not
new it's something we came up with in
the first energy crisis over 30 years
ago when we were asked by the european
commission to look at this issue so this
is when I moved to Illinois this student
or now a professor in Iowa State Emily
Heaton and was in my classes and said
well I want to try this plant in in
Illinois so we we grow it this one but
this is the most we've seen but this
particular crop was 60 dry tonnes per
hectare so one of the biggest yields of
anything in in the Midwest in one year
and I said I'd grown it in England
previously and this is this is in
kilograms per meter squared x 10
to get tons per hectare that's a
harvested yield of 20 tons per hectare
which is pretty well a record for
Britain but one of the big advantages of
these perennial grasses if you just want
the biomass is that they move their
nutrients into the shoots as they grow
in the spring in the autumn or fall they
move those nutrients back into the
perinatal organs in the soil so if you
harvest them late fall or early winter
you're leaving the nutrients behind and
in fact rothamsted in England now this
has been grown for 15 years we now added
nitrogen and if they do have nitrogen
they don't see a yield in increase so
very sustainable crops and this is these
are our trials in Illinois where we're
harvesting them late winter we compared
it with switchgrass which has been a
favor bioenergy crop but generally the
yields we've tamed with switchgrass were
quite a bit lower than with with the
miscanthus although that's not to say
that switchgrass doesn't have a role
this is just showing biomass
accumulation over the growing season for
miscanthus and for switchgrass the
important thing is that miscanthus is
putting a lot of biomass into the soil
so we've now got farmers interesting
than this for restoring their soil
carbon now of course wall champaign
county gets some of the highest maize
yields in the world so one of my
graduate students Frank Dolman and now
works for Monsanto was curious about Liz
miscanthus really better than maize and
he found it was indeed and the reason
was again if you look at solar radiation
over the growing season this is what a
modern maize cultivars capturing and
this is what miscanthus is capturing and
that's because miscanthus produces
function
leaves earlier and can maintain them
later and so it captures about sixty
percent more sunlight and then if we
look at the amount of biomass plotted
against interceptive radiation that
tells us the efficiency with these with
which these crops convert the
intercepted sunlight into biomass and
you can see that this is maize this is
miscanthus these lines are almost
identical so the difference is really
the maze can sorry miscanthus can just
do it for more of the year it can do it
in colder weather than maize can now it
isn't just you can get a good yield in
central Illinois these are some of the
European trials we had this is on the
west coast of Ireland this is on land
which historically we know has never
been plowed never been used apparently
for food crop Sonja that's 72 horsepower
tractor and there is au miscanthus crop
so it can grow on marginal soils very
successfully Fernando me guess who's now
also a professor at Iowa State was a
postdoc with me developed a mechanistic
model a very detailed model to really
predict where we might get good yields
in the u.s. ring fed yields and you can
see that it isn't just on these fertile
soils of the Midwest but also through
into much poorer soils in Georgia
Tennessee Alabama and so on indeed
tomboy a colleague of mine tom boy and a
grandmas now has trials there which
seemed to suggest that that is correct
so what could you do with this in terms
of bioenergy in the United States how
much lamb would you need well this is
these brown areas of the areas that we
now use for our primary if you like
made a row crops so most of it of course
is in the Midwest Mississippi Valley and
then right out here in the central
valley as well a lot of this land if you
had looked drawn this map a hundred
years ago a lot of this land would have
also been in row crops including parts
of western New York State which are not
not today so have a lot of lamb which
has dropped out of productivity
production that could be used so if if
you take this square as the amount of
the united states that we use for row
crops today 176 million hectares out of
almost a thousand million in the 48
states so about seventeen percent is in
row crop production how much will we
need to reach this goal which was to
produce about a third of liquid fuel
production the liquid fuels we need
produce about a third of them by 2030
for crop like miscanthus you would need
9.7 million hectares we have 11 million
in CRP and of course it doesn't just
have to be miscanthus you could also
think of crops like agave which can grow
on semi-arid land as well you need more
hectares but we have a lot of semi-arid
land which is really in quite poor
condition a lot of it degraded by early
settlement where you could even restore
soil carbon so it really wouldn't be a
large burden on the amount of land we
would need to do this and then we also
have the situation we're producing about
110 million tons of pole which is
declining in its need because we're
moving more and more to media like this
demand for Pope is is declining although
apparently some
users are still not going away so we
have those opportunities don't have
finish on biofuels by saying that there
are opportunities beyond cellulosic
ethanol as well and our pre which is a
branch of the Department of Energy put
out a call for some high-risk proposals
so together with Brookhaven National Lab
university of nebraska and of university
of florida we put together a proposal
where we said well sugar cane and sweet
sagar among the most productive plants
we have supposing we could get them to
accumulate oil in the stem instead of
sugar because you would get far more oil
per hectare then you could get from
canola or soybean and so we set about
trying to do this and it was a test of
concept but in two years we've managed
to get accumulation of oil in the stem
of about five percent we've identified
late stem promoters to attach the
constructs to and we've also engineered
photosynthesis in these plants to get
more productivity and we on a separate
line has been hybridizing shooting came
with miscanthus their close relatives to
try and um breeding improve cold
tolerance but these the engineering ones
have moved quite quickly this obviously
requires a lot of backcrosses before you
can really get back your original cane
and so so realize this is too small to
see but this is how much biodiesel you
could get per unit of land area this is
what we get today from soybean this is
what you can get from the came we have
now with five percent oil this is what
you get if we reach the theoretical
target I all the sugar ends up in oil
which will be about twenty percent of
the biomass in oil
and on this matter what you're seeing is
yellow is lamb which has been abandoned
from agriculture but could be used for
growing sugarcane so if we were to grow
an oil cane like this on that land it's
about 23 million acres about 10 million
hectares that would be about sixty nine
percent of that 2030 goal so I'd really
say that it is possible for the United
States to produce a very significant
amount of biofuel renewable by 2030
definitely by 2050 if we wanted to do it
now of course a lot of what I've been
telling you is transgenic technology so
you know what is inhibiting us really
from adapting this one is doubt that we
really need to worry about food
production because Malthus was a vicar
in Britain over 200 years ago who showed
mathematically populations rising
exponentially you is rising linearly a
point will come when starvation happens
he forecast that point about 200 years
ago and we've managed to avoid him
pretty well and we did reach a point
before the Green Revolution where it did
look iffy but that was overcome and he's
been overcome because we've had a series
of agricultural innovations of which the
Green Revolution was won the we forget
that going back 150 years ago the Haber
process which is where basically
originally coal was burnt to get
temperatures where you could convert am
spirit nitrogen into ammonia the source
of most of our nitrogen fertilizers
today probably allowing about four
billion more individuals on the planet
but I put it to you if the Hebrew
process was invented to
a would society be willing to accept
this dirty technology despite the huge
impact its had on food production and
then of course today we have the
availability of information and
disinformation which makes communication
of science critical and I think GMO is a
really a classic case where there's been
a complete failure in communication
because anyone with a reasonable
knowledge of plant genetics will realize
that taking one gene and putting it into
a known location in the genome is a much
safer technology than what we were doing
before which was if you like for example
taking a wild relative to get to get a
gene for disease resistance productivity
whatever crossing that into our crop
then backcrossing several times we get
our known gene in but we also end up
with many other genes whose function we
haven't often no idea about they could
be allergens they could even be
carcinogens but that's weak last letters
natural and acceptable yet the far more
precise technology is really am not
gaining much acceptability at least in
many areas of the world and yet at the
same time pretty well all of all of
today's insulin comes from genetically
modified organisms and somehow that's
been accepted and then I think it isn't
just our failure to communicate to the
electorate at large but the politicians
we've for example Florida became worried
about new bioenergy crops potentially
becoming invasive so it passed the law
saying that if you if you're going to
trial when these bioenergy crops you
have to take out a bond of several
million dollars in case it escapes but
there's a clause in the legislation
which says but if you're using the plant
for agriculture
you're exempt so to a biologist it makes
no sense if a plant is going to be
invasive it's going to be invasive
whatever your purpose and then we have
the California low carbon fuel standard
which will not accept ethanol from made
from maize but will accept ethanol made
from sugarcane so we had a year when
Brazil ran short of ethanol it imported
ethanol from the United States and
California imported ethanol back from
Brazil because that was considered
sustainable so apparently some molecules
of ethanol are different to other
molecules of ethanol so but we are
seeing things changing some of the
opponents of GM crops have changed their
position quite an hour proponents so
what I put to you is from a scientific
perspective we could have it all in 2050
weather policy and society will allow us
you will the perfect be the enemy of the
good in this situation we don't know and
if you want to know more about these
projects and there are two websites
right illinois.edu and petros
illinois.edu and these are some of the
many people who've worked in my lab and
and made it possible for give that
presentation so thank
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu